casi 60 años después llegó el pedido de
perdón para los harkis el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón dio un paso más
para reconocer a los argelinos que
lucharon en la guerra para francia entre
1954 y 1962 llegó aquí a love song for
water en él
les digo a los huskies y a sus hijos con
gran solemnidad que la república está en
deuda a los soldados me gustaría
reconocer los no les olvidaremos a
aquellos que han sido abandonados a sus
familias que han sufrido en campamentos
en cárceles que han sido negados les
pedimos perdón y no les olvidaremos con
la prisión blandín
se desmontaron
no me obligó un poco
tras la retirada gala de argelia en 1962
miles quedaron abandonados a su suerte y
fueron asesinados por las fuerzas
argelinas del frente de liberación
nacional
40.000 llegaron a francia y fueron
internados en campos de concentración
sufriendo discriminación una hija de un
ex combatiente interrumpió a macrón
denunciaba la imposibilidad de reparar
el daño
los gritos llegaron cuando macrón había
prometido una ley de reconocimiento para
los hard keys sin embargo otras víctimas
recibieron con entusiasmo el
reconocimiento y
parece que por primera vez un firme
deseo en torno a la verdad está guiando
al presidente de francia gracias por su
atención
viva la república viva francia en 2012
el ex presidente nicolas sarkozy
reconoció fallos del estado en 2016 el
ex presidente françois hollande
reconoció la culpabilidad
finalmente en 2021 macrón dio un paso
más antes en marzo ordenó desclasificar
documentos de estado hasta 1971
a cinco días del homenaje anual a los
hard keys llegó el esperado perdón